regardez il ya quelqu'un qui a de dire
s'il ya dansé avec une desperate
housewife j'ai été repéré dans le public
d'une émission de télé j'ai été candidat
dans motus accord j'ai participé la
nouvelle star j'ai écrit pour bernard
montiel
j'ai récemment proposé un projet
d'émission à ses huit ça c'est de leur
beau il a encore été refusée j'ai
rencontré le pape grâce à france 3 ça
c'est à morini-bosc de france 3 l'a déjà
annoncé en direct par erreur la mort de
pascal souvent ça c'est morini-bosc
aussi j'ai empêché benjamin castaldi de
frapper stéphane bern
ben je vois qu'ils s'attaquent à des
shows que je l'éliminé un superbe
champion dans pyramide et ben tous ont
fait ça même moi je ne sais pas alors il
y en a une je sais j'ai participé à la
nouvelle star c'est vous qui avez droit
oui parce que c'est vrai dans l'avenir
il va tout bleu si ça fait bizarre c'est
une grande chanteuse et courage et votre
nom à elle a fait des castings il ya dix
ans à 10 ans la féline casting ans a
marché
j'avais un prime je me suis rétabli mais
je sais faut prévenir oui alors on a des
images non ça nous a coûté un billet
j'ai précisé que je me suis rétabli un
jeu vous chantez maintenant quand c'est
quoi votre chanson préférée
non j'ai arrêté de chanter est prêt à
partir de là un petit truc non
[Applaudissements]
et après vous nous chanter un petit truc
10 secondes et je fais aux boys je me
retourne partiront du coup le joola sort
etc
[Musique]
nous avons connu isabelle magnifique
isabelle a tous les talents cela que je
suis chez moi tard mais il avait le péno
petites rues mais quoi non non c'est
horrible c'est gallas qui chante en ce
moment mais je chante plus maussade a
retenu ce alors là je me rappelle aussi
du du prêt mais c'était super bus avait
là c'est là que j'ai fou à l'elysée 3 2
c'est pas assez horrible qu'est ce que
je fais on domine mais les militants
remettiez barmes été j'ai été repéré
dans le public d'une émission de télé ça
c'est quelqu'un qui va certainement y
retourner j'ai été repéré dans le passé
gainey n'est pas moi j'aime bien c'est
vous maintenant banon classée vous c'est
tout cette afrique asa football club
canal shekels
mais c'est vrai moi et moi qui vous ai
repéré en plus dur mais je me rappelle
je vous avais mis derrière j'avais mis
de temps derrière brad ou oui exact
serveuse c'est vrai ouais j'avais vu
d'ici qui se meurt
c'est vrai vous repérer des talents
avoir beaucoup de vous repérer les
panneaux c'est fou comme je les repère
plus aussi un moment
[Applaudissements]
pendant l'émission et maquilleuse qui
vient de maquiller la bise n'était pas
maquillé dans le public oui et l'anzhi
mais pourquoi vous maquiller elle me dit
saluer 10 passe quelque chose sur
internet je peux pas vous dire vrai
après bon et ensuite hervé mathoux est
venu me voir dans les coulisses et
madison photos aussi
et apprendre si dans l'ensemble les
voitures appelle et vous étiez payer
pour être dans le public là bas oui
d'accord on est payé combien postes dans
le public
agca lui mais pas beaucoup sortis euros
jusqu'ici l'an 79 70 euros vous avez des
questions d info me demande s abat bravo
et surtout il vous étiez combien être
payés parce qu'on avait l'impression
qu'ils avaient une jolie fille qui
placent judas hervé mathoux alors été
sans faute 4 ou 5 85 s'efforce alors on
va regarder regarder oui assez canal on
paye pas j'avais l'image j'espère qu'on
les a pas
mais tous ont tourné les images wii vont
nous faire à procès je ne crois pas je
sais pourquoi je vois les cousins tu
fais des projets ta famille les nazis
oui on calme-toi d'amis calme toi tu es
en train de partir en cacahuète
attention j'ai été candidat dans motus
horse à la guinée n'ont pas de vrai que
lui il a les problèmes en plus de petits
mammoth dans motus c'est quelqu'un de
hoyos à jean-luc vous ai dit quelqu'un
diouf jean luc non mais parce que
j'avais fait intelligent c'est pire
abidjan et aime les boules non non j'ai
côtoyé quelqu'un qui va l'entraîner pour
participer à brutus mais j'ai jamais
franchi le car est alors que vous
regrettez vous fait rire c'est vous
elles vont rester au fait rire c'est par
les boules les mots si l'on poussé ma
vie les bouleversements comme jamais
participé a battu ce nom
ah non isabelle non mais c'est qu'ils
sont décodés cvo müllheim non c'est
benji web agréé participe à oui c'est
vrai aussi mais quand vous étiez connu
non pas du tout j'étais candidat et j'ai
été tellement mauvais sa race l'émission
a pas été diffusée mais c'est vrai non
mais à tel point que comme c'est mme
abena qui produit motus depuis depuis 20
ans elle a enlevé les missions pour que
jamais au grand jamais elle ne ressorte
et b1 quand je vous dis un désert c'est
aux horribles n'était pas connu non pas
connu pas du tout et ce n'est pas une
belle mère ouais donc vous aviez été
pistonné bien sûr le cas du bien sûr
gilles verdez faisant penser
aulas c'est une tragédie en mai mais il
y avait un dictionnaire à gagner il n'y
avait pas non plus eu mort d'homme mais
c'est vrai oui non mais quand je vous
dis mauvaise crois que c'est la plus
grande honte mais après j'ai pas trouvé
un mot est par exemple et vous avez
demandé à personne de le dire bah non
bien sûr
j'ai bien bougé si vous êtes plus frère
et vous étiez b qui s'était jeté
quelques copains qui est encore plus nul
que moi si vous comptez sur vous
j'écris pour bernard montiel
ah bah c'est quelqu'un qui sait écrire
déjà écrit quoi bien montrer mais
s'était pas créé un bouquin oui vidéo
gag à la fiche de vidéo gag s'affiche
tokyo gas to play jean luc lemoine c'est
vrai c'est vous c'est vrai des clips ou
bernard montiel pendant qu'il est au
point soleil votre 30 minutes face à l
écrit pour bernard montiel la classe
ouais ouais mais c'est comme ça ça m'a
lancé c'est un tremplin vers le nom ce
qui s'est passé c'est que c'était un
prime de vidéo gag et la productrice
m'avait dit gentiment s'il te plaît dans
le chaudron turc mais bien bonsoir ça ne
le dira pas non
voilà mais ce qui était faux parce que
bernard est beaucoup plus intelligent
mais ça et à l'époque il présentait avec
une co présentatrice olivia adriaco
exactement où en étaient les lieux mais
avec j'écrive avec un pote et il ya
toujours un magnéto sur le sur les
enfants perdus ils disent à eva silva
neto de nos jolies têtes blondes doc
nous on s'est dit on va faire un truc si
le plus original
on avait fait un truc est maintenant un
petit magnéto pour si toutes ces
personnes qui plus tard perron de
retraite arrivée en fumée il est hors de
question qu'on passe vos idées
politiques c'est pas possible
et donc on s'est fait sécher on nous a
renvoyé le texte avec gwen français
s'est fait recaler de vidéo gag
la vraie info c'est quand même y avait
des prime de vidéo gag ouais mais ça
l'est non seulement il ya des premiers
video games sas des 12 millions alors
j'ai écouté ali j'ai envie de savoir moi
j'ai empêché benjamin castaldi de
frapper stéphane bern çà çà çà tu sûr
que c'est de leur mot restait plus que
non sa cote est une bagarre je peux me
chauffer à ses réponses à 100 l'émission
sur tf1 s'en occupe et diana non c'est
moi non c'est la wii valérie bénaïm vous
avez empêché benjamin castaldi de
frapper stéphane bern exact est ce que
c'est que cette histoire dans un instant
doha les captures de jean luc lemoine
oreilles trop fait
vers un camelot minutes on a les
trophées du bost bim frère de laëtitia
l'hymne garde à vue une affiche
française dans l'es6 et pour les voodoo
sylvie vartan qui balancent dans les
médias on aura son avocat olivier
chiabodo menacé par tefe connaissez
l'histoire intervilles vim
la troisième réponse il va nous
expliquer ce qui s'est passé qui a
triché
qui a fait quoi l'inde a menacé on saura
tout tout tout tout sur beinheim
également ces partis fédéraux alors voir
brushing manificat bon bien sûr merci
ah oui je pars comme ça sera peut-être
de l'aveyron on dirait qu'un surfeur qui
va arriver
il meurt bientôt avoir un coeur comme à
son père alors la tête histoire c'est
que je vais présenter avec un stéphane
et benjamin célérité sur quoi il a été
présentateur lui aussi non j'en aie été
chroniqueur à l'accord chroniqueurs et
donc le chroniqueur de stéphane et et de
noël nous présentions duo donc
célébrités et pendant l'émission je ne
sais pour quelle raison je pense un peu
en vannes quand même c'était femme a dit
à benjamin qui c'était un prolo lourdaud
alors est-ce que vous pouvez le faire
vous stéphane bern oui bonsoir chrono
lourdaud monseigneur j'ai pas lui
demander de le refaire mais c'est pas
tant mais bravo maxim's ait tout de
suite bein entraînements en même temps
il n'a pas changé sa voix donc
et vous savez comme d'un charmant est un
peu soupe au lait non mais j'ai très
bien ce moment c'est tout le contraire
de moi bah oui bien ça que j'ai bien sûr
on partait pas dans les tours comme lui
très rapidement et ben quoi qu'est ce
qu'il a fait et donc du coup il lui a
dit je vais te casser la gueule
stephen harper à la fin de l'émission
est parti si ça dans sa loge il s'est
enfermé la solution c'est le piéton
meurt comment ça doit me casser la
gueule non
il s'est enfermé dans l'âge parce qu'il
avait la trouille mais moi j'étais
enceinte à l'époque est enceinte qui
fait barrage
non non non non tu ne vas pas tu ne
feras pas tu auras pas le seul rennais
fera pas les gens et oui ça on ne fera
pas les gens à l'ag aura pas la langue
sinon je veux sortir tout seul
cinq bateaux trouves tu vas boire j'ai
tout chà toute personne en uc
[Rires]
alors laissez bon on va pas tous les
faire et donc ça c'est benhaim j'avais
envie de savoir un truc franchement j'ai
annoncé en direct par erreur la mort de
pascal sevran
je pense savoir qu'ici je pensais semedo
leurs mots tout à fait coiffer du grand
journalisme vous avez annoncé la mort de
passer devant
c'est un fait il était vivant voilà bah
merci bas on voit toujours les bonnes
infos j'ai rencontré le patron grâce à
france 3 le feu ravage 3 isabelle way
avec l'épître de paul ii bah oui bah oui
mash up old ou à paul ii et 7 ans j'y
suis allé en plein été c'est à castel
gandolfo avec un gars m'a jeté la
patronne de jury d'une émission de
france 3 qui s'appelait c'est pas juste
excellente émission où en sont les
déchets dits d'accord allez voir le pape
donc on y est allé et j'étais enceinte
de huit mois
ouais et j'avais perdu mon argent dans
l'avion ce qui fait que j'ai pas osé le
dire à la production qui m'a dit c'est
ton hôtel je dis oui j'ai touché deux
nuits sur un banc public et la seconde
nuit ils m'ont embarqué au poste d un
syndrome qui couchent tout seul sur un
banc public
je leur ai dit je dois voir le pape et
le lendemain matin ils m'ont libéré il y
en un caddie à l'autre cette femme
prétend que le pape et le père avait
évidemment jamais dit ça au commissariat
et moi je parle pas italien je parle
espagnol
c'est tout donc ça a été pénible c'est
l'export était pénible galles
[Applaudissements]
allez donc merci ça quand même
j'ai allongé éliminer un superchampion
dans pyramide se susurre que sagat aux
poudres ouais c'est ça excusez moi ça
veut dire que celui qui est proposé un
projet d'émission assez vite c'est
verdez bas apparemment oui c'est pour ça
qu'on a jamais tout vous avez jamais
chaîne non non on l'a alors m'a dit jean
michel larqué
j'ai cherché trois heures le message de
la prod à 17h faudrait qu'à une anecdote
c'est vrai qu'après c'est difficile
j'ai beaucoup de peine bah ouais merci
c'est vrai que la vérité peut faire de
la peine à aa oui vous vous donc vous
vous avez fait vous allez battre
superchampion de pyramide oui ils vont
sénat même pu l'emporter mais pas merci
merci merci beaucoup c'est tout
il faut que j'arrête non bah oui moi non
mais c'est vrai un papa bravo mais elle
elle est très fort contre votre mère est
prof non on déconne la france et
wellington entre potes de français
madame ça je veux dire les chiens ne
font pas des chats on va pas non plus se
mentir
ce qui est acquis sida me regarder comme
ça le jour et l'heure du tigre
l'habituel regarde gilles verdez le ciet
2 on sait qu'une des spectateurs vous
aurez c'est vous non c'est vous vois que
vous avez dansé qu'une des spectateurs
vous savez je ne suis pas le dernier
pour faire la nouba
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je ne suis pas tarder pour faire la
nouba et chaque année je au festival de
télévision de monte-carlo internationale
qui se passe donc à monaco
et c'était à la clôture il se faisait
tard aux alentours de 22 heures et le
bled de stars et j'ai repéré lynette
scavo dans desperate housewives felicity
huffman et je me suis saignée que c'est
maintenant ou jamais parce que je
pouvais accéder au même titre que les
autres sur l'épisode danse y avait le
live de kool and the gang
en parallèle et bien sûr il ya le prince
albert dès que vous faites quelque chose
tout de suite ça des regards
ah oui alors canard enchaîné rationnelle
et je veux lui demander je lui demandai
je lui demande à celle fille sauf que
dit lorsque je dis aux possibles doivent
s'y tenir
je dirais tu si bolt ou dance with you
hell majorité est sauvé et elle ne frôle
elle le prend la main ont fait un petit
tour
ça a duré quelques secondes non corses
sont en diable et s'est déplacé pour la
première fois je n'ai
[Applaudissements]
la première fois vous avez l'impression
tout dur pour la première fois je
n'étais pas discrète et vous avez prouvé
à se produire s'est vite le ciel est
lourd mais mon esprit et les géants mais
faites vite parce qu'on est con mais
vraiment on s'en bat l'oeil total car
oui absolument
quant à julien lalande le 21 février
2010 est une super émission fantôme ovni
sorciers ils sont parmi nous des
témoignages exclusifs un truc de dingue
et vous savez ce qui s'est passé j'ai
jamais aucune réponse événement célébré
pas demandé la barça j'ai fait une
erreur et vous savez quoi sur la tête de
ma mère et on doit en effet on va le
faire
leers et vous savez qu'on va le faire
non demain ce soir donc vous dire on va
le faire demain sur la tête de ma mère
devant saint-etienne peu spécial c'est
quoi fantôme ovni sorciers ils sont
parmi nous ils seront pas parmi nous
mais on va le faire sur la tête de ma
mère
[Rires]
j'ai fait la porte un tchador alou
diarra ramène des témoignages